[Musique]
bonjour à tous je suis ravi de vous
retrouver aujourd'hui dans ce nouveau
numéro du skycho alors pour cette
nouvelle édition je vous emmène avec moi
découvrir le monde de la défense
spatiale car ici à l'observatoire de
versaill saquanttin en iine se déroule
laacaton desfin space 2023 ici une
soixantaine d'étudiants vont tenter
d'imaginer des solutions pour la défense
spatiale de demain en seulement 24 Hees
ce défi se déroulera simultanément dans
plusieurs villes françaises mais aussi à
travers le monde on en reparlera plus
tard dans cette édition du Sky echo mais
tout de suite voici le sommaire
rencontre avec Mathilde ballouire
fondatrice d'utopique 78 une ambition de
longue date devenue réalité mathilde
baloire a lancé utopique 78 en août 2023
une entreprise inclusive qui souhaite
former et accompagner les personnes
éloignées de l'emploi rencontre define
space 24 heures pour imaginer la défense
spatiale de demain le 17 et 18 novembre
2023 une soixantaine d'étudiants se
rassemblaient à l'observatoire de
Versailles sa an iine pour relever un
défi de taille inventer la défense
spatiale du futur clap de fin pour le
dispositif ensemble à 100 %. il
proposait aux habitants de 50 an ivin
qui le voulit un parcours qui leur
permettait de se remobiliser bilan de
cette grande
[Musique]
aventure un vieux rêve devenu réalité
depuis 3 mois mathilde balouard a ouvert
son entreprise d'insertion dans les
métiers de la restauration son nom
utopique 78 un projet de longue date qui
a mis 10 ans à voir le jour j'ai
toujours eu l'esprit
d'entreprendre je je voulais vraiment
créer une entreprise à mon image en fait
voilà donc avec l'insertion
professionnelle au cœur de notre métier
et aussi autour de la restauration pour
offrir du plaisir aux personnes une
démarche solidaire fondamentale car
l'ambition première du topic 78 c'est
accompagner et de former des personnes
éloignées de l'emploi l'objectif c'est
de lever tous les freins à l'emploi
aujourd'hui on a deux personnes en
insertion et un encadrant technique chef
de cuisine qui les accompagne ils ont un
parcours de 2 ans maximum au sein de du
toopic 78 pour accéder à l'emploi
durable nous on va les accompagner déjà
sur la remise à l'emploi sur
l'acquisition de compétences techniques
par la formation qui va être délivrée
par l'encadr technique mais également
par des formations
qu'on va pouvoir leur financer par
ailleurs un défi de taille pour cette
ancienne directrice d'agence d'intérim
qui ne connaissait rien à la vie
d'entrepreneur il fallait que je me crée
les compétences que je n'avais pas en
gestion d'entreprise en management pour
la construction de mon business plan
j'ai été accompagné par BGE au ski cube
ensuite pour le financement j'ai
également été accompagné par deux
structures qui sont initiative 51 qui
est présente au ski cube aussi et France
Active également et je suis accompagnée
aussi dans le cadre de mon lancement de
projet autour de l'esss par émergence et
Lab trempelin donc en fait tous les
freins que j'avais et les difficultés
ils sont levés grâce à l'accompagnement
des structures qui sont présentes sur le
territoire ces structures n'ont pas
seulement aidé mathil baloir à acquérir
des compétences elles ont également levé
des freins qui empêchaient la jeune
femme d'atteindre ses rêves les
difficultés en tant que femme je me les
mets moi-même c'est-à-dire que je vais
plutôt penser que je suis moins bonne ou
moins performante que que d'autres mais
c'est pareil enfin j'ai beaucoup de
bienveillance autour de moi de tous les
partenaires que je rencontre pour la
suite Mathilde baloir voit grand elle
souhaiterait agrandir sa brigade en
insertion et pourquoi pas développer son
activité sur d'autres
[Musique]
sites 24 heur pour imaginer la défense
spatiale de demain c'est le défi lancé
par le commandement de l'espace et le
pôle de compétitivité Aérospace Valley
une opportunité unique de découvrir
l'univers peu connu de la défense
spatiale les enjeux futurs et les
nouveaux métiers qui vont en découler
tout à l'heure le top départ a été lancé
une soixantaine d'étudiants et
d'étudiantes sont mobilisés pour tenter
d'imaginer des solutions pour la défense
spatiale de demain pour en parler je
suis avec Philippe kekut vous êtes
physicien à l'observatoire de Versailles
50 an evening et vice-président
recherche et innovation en charge de
l'organisation de cet acasson bonjour
bonjour alors premièrement qu'est-ce que
c'est que ce défi ins space ce défi in
space c'est c'est c'est un un mode de de
travail qui est qui qui est différent
d'habitude c'est que d'un seul coup on
se dit on a 24 heures pour essayer
d'imaginer quelque chose et du coup on
on mobilise ces neurones pour aller
trouver des solutions qu'on nait pas
imaginé jusque là d'accord et donc
comment ça s'est organisé ce alors c'est
le commandement de l'espace qui vient
d'être créé et il a été créé parce que
le domaine du spatial est en pleine
évolution en ce moment de tous les
niveaux et du coup bien évidemment il y
a des questions de souveraineté des
questions militaires associées et et des
des questions aussi d'encombrement de
l'espace plein de questions qui
finalement sont très importants pour
notre vie au quotidien puisqu'on on
dépend beaucoup du satellite les gens
l'ignorent mais presque toute notre vie
dépend des satellites aujourd'hui
maintenant et donc on a besoin
effectivement de de de enrichir
finalement ce que on peut faire et et et
la vision que l'on a pour demain et donc
pourquoi est-ce que ce ce défi pardon a
été lancé concrètement alors ben comme
je vous disais le commandement de
l'espace cherche à impliquer tout le
monde euh cherche à s'appuyer sur tous
les talents et du coup le akaton c'est
une manière effectivement de montrer
aussi aux étudiants qu' qu'on n pas dans
un aspect militaire de guerre mais
militaire au sens de la souveraineté de
de de de défendre effectivement nos
équipements contre des attaques
éventuelles mais aussi contre le milieu
qui est très hostile
donc tout le monde
est est intéressé par ça donc c'est
c'est de montrer que finalement le
spatial ne ne se limite pas à Thomas
Pesquet ou Elon Musk qui a beaucoup
beaucoup de d'éléments et que et qu'on a
besoin de tout le monde se mobiliser sur
le spatial c'est un domaine qui va être
ouvert largement à un beaucoup plus
grand nombre de et à l'issue de ces 24
heures qu'est-ce que vous attendez de
ces étudiants alors nous nous on a on
attend effectivement euh que les
étudiants réfléchissent et puis
finalement travaillent collectivement
euh donc nous pour nous c'est aussi un
exercice pédagogique de de travailler de
cette manière-là après c'est le
commandement de l'espace qui a une
commande mais nous là on est on est une
étape puisqu'il y a une dizaine de sites
en France et même en Europe qui
participe et donc le gagnant de notre
organisation locale participera à une
finale au niveau national ouais et
combien de personnes participent à ce
projet alors là on a du mobilisé une
soixantaine d'étudiants qui viennent
alors soit c'est des des des des fanas
du spatial soit c'est des gens qui sont
en formation souvent en Master et du
coup qui là vont vont vont effectivement
essayer de travailler ensemble sur des
cas concrets puisque ils sortent
finalement de de de cas un peu théoriqu
là ils vont avoir un cas concret à
essayer d'imaginer et donc il y a aussi
des encadrants qui sont là alors il y a
des encadrants et c'est c'est et c'est
tout l'intérêt du acaton en présentiel
c'est-à-dire que on a des coachs qui
viennent les aider en leur transmettant
leur expérience mais bien évidemment on
espère qu'ils vont aller au-delà
d'imaginer le demain donc on a des gens
d'Airbus on a des gens d'Arian group on
a des gens de tous les gros groupes et
puis on a des gens qui viennent de
start-up aussi et puis on a bien
évidemment les scientifiques ici
puisqu'on est quand même dans un
laboratoire ici qui faisons au quotidien
des instruments sp pour la recherche et
donc on a aussi nous on est aussi très
intéressé par les questions que que pose
le le le le le commandement de l'espace
on a nous-même des constellations donc
tout puisque la la question là qui qui
leur est posé c'est à propos des
constellations qu'est-ce qu'on fait de
nos constellations comment on les gère
au mieux et ben nous on a des
constellations scientifiques donc on est
aussi intéressé par finalement la
question qui est posée par le par le
gouvernement de par par le commandement
de l'espace pour pour essayer d'avancer
dans dans Comment on a une stratégie
nationale et collective d' et c'est la
première fois qu'il y a un tel événement
qui se passe non alors on est la 3e
édition bien évidemment ces événements
commencent toujours petit et et
finissent par grossir donc ça ça prouve
l'intérêt qu'à qu'à tout le monde et là
du coup on s'est proposé nous de
l'organiser sur Paris pour deux raisons
d'une part parce que on
a fait beaucoup d'effort aussi sur les
aspects pédagogiques donc on a des
formations à l'université autour de ça
donc on on a envie de les mettre
vraiment dans sur des cas concrets et
puis on a aussi un projet qui qui va
avec c'est que au niveau de
l'Île-de-France on a été lauréat d'unun
d'un projet France 2030 compéten métier
d'avenir autour du spatial et là on se
retrouve avec d'autres universités
d'île-de-fance pour essayer de réfléchir
ensemble à une formation qui soit qui
soit logique en France et et compatible
avec des parcours intelligent et donc
toutes ces universités travaillent
ensemble à à à à ce défi et le acathon
c'est c'est un des éléments possibles
euh de de cette pédagogie et à la fin il
y a une remise de prix qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce qu'on va gagner à la fin alors
euh il y a deux étapes hein il y a il y
a le local euh où là euh les les les les
les vainqueurs vont gagner effectivement
euh un un un un accès euh aux
installations des gios euh on est on est
à Guill encour qui est très impliqué sur
sur sur sur les Jos et puis après
l'étape d'après c'est gagner la finale
nationale et là c'est une visite à
courou HM d'accord super ben merci
beaucoup en tout cas et justement bah on
va aller rencontrer certains de ces
étudiants tout de suite qui sont en
train de travailler sur les
[Musique]
travaux pourquoi tu as participé à ce
défi in space aujourd'hui alors moi je
m'intéresse beaucoup au domaine de la
défense et notamment la défense spatiale
donc je trouve que c'était assez
important quand même que je puisse
participer à ce à ce à ce challenge donc
là en fait on a choisi le défi technique
donc du coup on va devoir trouver donc
une enfin une application enfin
plusieurs applications du moins de
satellite et de constellation civiles au
domaine militaire ben je trouvais que ça
peut être sympa de faire ça avec des
camarades de classe et que c'est une
bonne opportunité de découvrir un peu
plus le ministère des armées et les
constellations de satellite on choisi le
sujet technique du coup on est en train
de de s'intéresser aux besoins du
ministère des armées et après on
regardera les constellations qui
existent déjà qui pourrai besoindre à
qui pourrait répondre à ses besoins mes
amis participent et qu'avec sa FO on
était extrêmement motivés au final ils
nous ont rejoint dans l'équipe et on
espère qu'on va gagner euh oui c'est la
première fois et c'est la première fois
pour tout le monde ici mais on verra ce
que ça va donner plutôt excité pas trop
stressé ni l'un ni l'autre ni excité ni
stressé très serein ça ira ok super
motivé oui motivé bon on va les laisser
travailler parce qu'il rendre leurs
travaux demain à 15h on leur souhaite à
tous bon courage et nous on par à encs
au campus numérique pour la clôture du
dispositif ensemble à 100
[Musique]
%. après 2 ans d'expérimentation le
dispositif ensemble à 100 % se clôture
il proposait des parcours à la carte
pour remobiliser et accompagner des
personnes éloignées de l'emploi le tout
grâce au numérique c'est un dispositif
expérimental qui vise à accompagner des
personnes que l'on appelle invisible
dans les quartiers prioritaires de la
politique de la ville qui sont en fait
des personnes éloignées de l' emploi et
qui sont pour certaines d'entre elles
même plus inscrites à Pôle emploi et
cetera les accompagner pour les ramener
vers la formation et vers l'emploi pour
ça on on utilise le numérique non pas
comme forcément un savoir-faire mais
beaucoup plus comme un moyen pour
pouvoir aller plus vite pour pouvoir
être plus dynamique pour pouvoir rester
relié avec les autres personnes et
avancer à son rythme mais toujours dans
l'engagement et dans une aventure de de
remobilisation en quelques chiffres
ensemble à 100 % c'est 2 ans de
programme d' sociale expérimentale
l'accompagnement de plus de 450
personnes éloignées de l'emploi
l'accompagnement de 267 jeunes de moins
de 26 ans et 227 femmes c'était vraiment
éclatant parce que en fait c'est cette
démarche c'est une démarche qui va
révéler les la les capacités des gens ce
qu'on appelle l'empowerment la
capacitation donc c'est vraiment cool
vous avez des gens qui arrivent chez
nous qui sont plein de doutes qui ont
l'impression qu'il sont pas capables qui
savent pas très bien ce qu'ils vont
faire et puis en fait dans cette
dynamique qui à la fois une dynamique
collective et individuelle ils vont se
révéler se découvrir des talents prendre
confiance en eux oser postuler à des
choses et cetera donc c'est vraiment
très cool de voir comme ça les gens
comme éclore et comme se révéler à
eux-mêmees grâce à ensemble à 100 % 25 %
des bénéficiaires sont entrés en
formation à la fin du parcours 17 % sont
en emploi durable CDI et CDD de plus de
6 mois deux des bénéficiaires ont créé
leur entreprise ce que j' tir c'est
beaucoup de
positif puisque ça m'a permis
aujourd'hui certes de trouver un emploi
mais également d'interagir avec beaucoup
de personnes
passionnées qui dans leur domaine ont à
cœur de de les partager j'ai aussi un
peu plus de connaissance sur qu'est-ce
qu'on a besoin sur le territoire et
comment je peux me rendre utile à
travers les compétences numériques que
j'ai acquises j'ai fini auto
entrepreneur ce qui n'était pas le
projet de base j'ai fini a temp
entrepreneur et je suis plus que fière
des connaissances
et des des liens tis on est vraiment à
l'air du numérique et tout le monde a
besoin pas de se sentir à l'aise dans le
numérique donc ça c'est vraiment en plus
c'est pas du gâi c'est pas du temps
perdu c'est vraiment en plus 100 %
gratuit ce dispositif était financé par
le ministère du travail de l'emploi et
de l'insertion et par la banque des
[Applaudissements]
territoires
on termine avec l'agenda ce mois-ci ne
manquez pas la Semaine de l'industrie du
27 novembre au 3 décembre 2023 plongé
dans le monde de l'industrie de
l'innovation et de la technologie
française la conférence du club climat
énergie le 28 novembre prochain de 9h à
15h rencontrer les entreprises et les
collectivités qui se sont adapté
notamment en terme de soberriété
[Musique]
énergétique c'est la fin de ce numéro
merci de l'avoir suivi à bientôt sur
[Musique]
tv78